[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
welcome to the squad ride live in the
bleacher report
app we are gathered here today for a
very important moment
you guys are going to decide our nfl
squad ride of the year
whatever you pick we are riding as a
family all season long
so get in the comments because we're
giving away a playstation 5. it's not
even out yet but we're giving away a
playstation 5.
a copy of madden 2021 we have cash and a
bunch of exclusive br betting hoodies
you know you guys know how much you love
them we love giving them to you so we're
giving those away
my friends adam lefko master chesfation
and the babyface assassin greg
ivory have come prepared to pitch you
their favorite nfl
futures bets and then you're going to
decide our nfl squad ride of the year
to help you we have betting expert kelly
stewart
and texas legend and two-time pro bowler
vince young
judging the pitches but the squad's
faced
fate is ultimately in your hands lefko
will be holding down the comments
so fire off your hot takes he's gonna be
giving away hoodies
so let us know how you feel especially
about lefko's sports card collection
if you want rookies he's got him dm him
and at the end of the show
one commenter again is going to get a
playstation 5
and a copy of madden 2021 and you know
what
we're actually in a in a giving we're
going to start the show by giving some
stuff away
that's how we do here on squad ride so
we asked you on br betting social
to tell us your favorite vince young
mode
and the response is overwhelming because
vince you're mvp of what is arguably the
greatest college football game
in the history of ever when you went
into usc's house
and won the super bowl june january 4
2006
um so vince question for you is how
often does that national championship
ring
make its appearance in public
it don't make an appearance at all
because it's locked up in the safe
deposit box
what it made one appearance
yeah it made one appearance but other
than that i put it up i don't want
nobody you can get hit up
i can get hit over the head and somebody
can take that thing from me
if you don't take my bet today vince
that's what might happen i'm coming for
that box
[Laughter]
uh but our but our favorite comment
vince came from
ronnie the ruler one and he writes
try fourth and 18th in the 2004 season
when vince pulled off that incredible
conversion against kansas and led the
horns to victory
v y was a video game cheat code in that
one and pretty much
every other game after that so ronnie we
are sending you a code for matt in 2021
to check your dms
vince what do you remember about that
specific game in that play
or that moment what i remember about
that is
aaron rodgers still pissed off about
that game
because we ended up taking the rose bowl
game over them
playing michigan and california cal was
supposed to go we ended up
playing that game so when i played in
for green bay
that's the first thing aaron rodgers
said man you know we're supposed to play
in that michigan game
and we're on the reason we went because
we because we won that game against
kansas that fourth and eighteen play
saved our season to go play michigan for
the in the rose bowl game
so yeah that's what i remember about
that game had an ass on
why why are the texas longhorns always
21 and a half point favorites and on the
ropes to the kansas jayhawks i just
don't get it i don't know it's i guess
cause it's cold
it's
it is time for our first pitch first of
three pitches
adam lefko is going to try to convince
you to follow his lead
on our squad ride of the year so drop
your reactions in the comments
one commenter will win a playstation 5
and a copy of madden 2021 shout out to
the lamar jackson on the cover
at the end of the show adam does it
concern you that the only person
in the world who is immune to your charm
is our betting expert kelly stewart
i'm gonna win her over but that's why
i'm gonna focus on vince and the people
in the br
app that are hitting me up be our mikey
locks you're gonna have to keep that
debt let me tell you a story about mvp i
wanna make you guys money we're putting
in our squad bet now
we're not gonna touch it for months
let's get value mvp
you're not going to get valuma homes
you're not going to get value in lamar
jackson we have to go with somebody that
the media loves
and that there's a storyline behind you
see those names up there
oh they seem great you know who's never
won an mvp in his career
and he's a first ballot hall of famer
the guy three from the bottom
drew brees plus 2200 his saints are
favorite to have one of the best seasons
in the nfl this year
they got too deep everywhere they got
two centers just to keep them safe
they finally got a number two wide
receiver and emanuel sanders
and the thing is this does he have the
strongest arm no
will it last into the playoffs maybe not
but i just need the regular season
i just need 16 games of 13-3 saints
football
and everyone goes g-god darn it can you
believe drew brees doesn't have an mvp
yet this is crazy and then someone goes
better give it to him
drew brees plus 22.
adam is that your texas no that was my
kansas accent
jokes vince vince what did you think of
adam's pitch
i just feel like he's drinking too much
coffee for one
ginger ale you know
drew brees is my texas boy he's a texas
guy he checks his quarterback but
he was supposed to win the mvp last year
but he got hurt
so i don't think he'll do it this year
so i think that's a bad bet right there
big guy
so you need to uh probably change that
to tom brady
that's not a bad point i'm just trying
to get that money [ __ ] just trying to
get that money
i don't hate your bet listen i'll put it
like this
i do think the saints are going to be
in the playoffs i do think the saints
will win 11 or 12
games this year i'm just not so
sure that drew brees is going to win mvp
there is a lot of guys
on that list if lamar jackson takes his
team
i haven't had a back-to-back mvp in 12
years listen
listen no doubt patrick mahomes takes
his team to us he's got to throw for six
hours
over here
there's a reason why he's 22-1 and i
just
don't see it and that's my problem with
your pick
if anything if you're going to go for a
long shot i think you got to go who the
patches name their starter a few minutes
ago
i think it's i think that says a lot
about him and how well he's been doing
with bill belichick vince young just
mentioned
tom brady uh we'll see how brady does
this year without
angry coach b in the cut cut-off hoodie
but i think cam newton's going to thrive
in foxboro i'm really excited to see
what he's able to do and at 33-1
draftkings is just giving away money
here
how do you have so much belief in a 41
year old quarterback though that
couldn't stay healthy last season and
there's a big reason why the saints
needed to sign jameis winston
to have some sort of security blanket
for them because the simple matter of
fact is
drew brees is old he's washed i'm not
saying he's done
but yo that arm's gonna fall off by week
12 man
i don't know how you expect him to stay
healthy for a 16-game season
when he couldn't stay healthy last
season that's my biggest issue with this
here
i think they're gonna be depending a lot
more on the running game however this
alvin kamara contract works out i think
they're gonna have to rely on kamara
and latavius murray a lot more in terms
of how that offense operates
but that shift has to happen so you can
cert keep maintaining drew brees's arm
because the biggest concern that they're
gonna have is making sure they can
maintain that arm
into the postseason because they're
clearly built for the postseason that's
why
i am not sold on having drew brees three
22-1
he's gonna be able to do it man i just
can i say say one more thing
yes sir yesterday thank you for watching
go for a great
[Laughter]
all i got to say to you left co is you
do realize he's 41 years old so that
means that arm is 41.
that means the tendons in that arm is
41. the ligaments is 41.
he's getting old i don't i don't craig i
want you to know
right now i am not 41 but i'm in some of
the best shape of my life
i need you to stop with the old people
don't put your heart
throwing 10 000 pounds your arm that's
the thing that i don't understand
is how everybody can talk about how
lebron's in year 17 and brady's in year
20 and we only do it for certain guys
meanwhile vince can attest to this vince
is drew brees one of the best
conditioned older athletes that in the
nfl
be honest
damn that was unnecessary
i'll say this as a final thing
the story the storyline of the mvp
is sometimes bigger than just statistics
can't you see what happened
earlier this offseason where brees said
some very regrettable things about the
national anthem
but then the team malcolm jenkins to
mario davis come around
in the city of new orleans and they come
and they have this crazy season to get
him his first mvp
for me it's like jim nance handing it
over with the tie and everything it
writes itself
i'm done back to you caviar that was
that was
that sounds good you're supposed to win
let's talk about all these disney stores
you want to we're going to live in
reality over here that ain't happening
it's a great pitch uh
please let us know how the audience
received that pitch
okay so it's really all over the place
uh but i'm i'm enjoying this a lot uh
i've seen
some desean watson is a dark horse here
um justin panner says adam take wence or
allen if you want great value
hudson underscore allah says lefko's
gonna go broke on this one
uh and then i think my favorite one was
from
yes russell wilson three and it's in all
caps
stop it stop it this is rigged when will
the haters stop sleeping on russell
wilson
this is atrocious left go stick to
basketball
i love russell wilson if he wins i won't
even be upset but the comments are going
crazy cabbie
they are on fire thank you very much for
that okay well listen
uh commenters we have some money to give
away 500 bucks in my pocket
that i need to give to somebody watching
this show so we asked on social
we asked you to guess how many dimples
are on a football
and not just any football this football
nfl football from wilson
uh tell us in the comments whether you
think there are over or under
10 000 dimples
we actually counted we had one of our
producers
sit at their kitchen table spend a
saturday or sunday and counted
the number of dimples on a football this
information is not
available on the only place you can find
this information is right here on the
squad ride
because this uh our producer put it did
the lord's work so
yeah uh vince you've thrown 46
touchdowns in the nfl
your best guess over or under 10
000 dimples on a football
gotta go under i don't know yeah under
man i'm taking the end it's been going
with that live
i'm underdog so i'm gonna go with
everything underdog life baby
pour a ginger ale and ride the over it's
more fun
get that open you're very rarely an
underdog so this one would be
new terrain for you so one commenter who
bets correctly
will be chosen to win 500 bucks we're
gonna let you know in a few minutes
um our let's get to let's get back to
our pitches so again we're asking you to
decide
our nfl future bet our nfl squad ride of
the year
and remember to drop your takes in the
comments and uh one commenter is gonna
win
a playstation five again these aren't
even out yet but someone's gonna win one
and a copy of madden
2021 vince are you gonna give your the
the playstation five that you were
promised to our commenter or
should we then source one one two
i think i think vince has a has a line
on a playstation 5.
man i'm not giving nobody my my
playstation they can forget about it
me and my son gonna be playing that
thing all night
[Laughter]
can't wait to jump online to challenge
you okay so uh you just heard adam
lefkow
pitch you drew brees at plus 2200 on
draftkings to win
nfl mvp now it's time to hear from my
favorite texas laureate
a journalist a scholar master tess
the mic is yours let me take this mic
off this this little thing right here
real quick
this one right here is for russell
wilson three
cause look i'm a cowboys fan all right
but
i hear you i feel you and i'm going with
the seahawks
to win the super bowl at 20 to one and
you know why baby
mr unlimited the man himself i got him
winning mvp
i got the seahawks winning the nfc west
they are loaded offensively
dk metcalf tyler lockett greg olsen they
just signed flash gordon baby let's go
they got a trio of running backs there
dude yes they have some injury concerns
however i expect two of the three to be
able to stay healthy
between chris carson rashad penny and a
very underrated signing in carlos hyde
who i think will be very key down the
stretch
for the seahawks and of course who could
who could forget baby oh yeah bro
you wasn't watching carlos high last
year that's right you were an honors fan
i forgot
you still mad about carlos hyde it's all
good baby you're going
twice a year it's all good baby but
guess what we forget about the biggest
piece
we forget about the biggest piece that
the seahawks were able to add and that's
jamal adams and we saw what the chiefs
were able to do when they added a
bonafide safety and what that did to
that defense
and i expect the same thing to happen to
seahawks the legion of boom
is back baby they have the best
secondary in the league
hands down i think that defense gets the
job done give me the seahawks man
go hawks
man adam i think he's drinking that tea
with you baby
yes sir yes sir vy he drinking it he's
sipping for skipping for
sure hey y'all over there sleeping y'all
sleeping on them rams man i'm telling
y'all
y'all sleeping on them rams over there
oh vy you might be sipping through yeah
you dipping but i ain't sipping no
cheeto
[Laughter]
kelly get in here what are your thoughts
on on masters pitch
you know i like masters pitch it makes
sense look seattle has one of the
easiest schedules in the nfl this year i
i think you have awesome weapons in dk
metcalf
tyler lockett most notably russell's
like bff these days i love
when you have a team with cohesion why
because we had no mini camp
we had no preseason or very limited
amounts of time for these teams to be
playing together
this offense is essentially the same as
it was last
season i think there's some good value
here because i do
i already personally bet uh seahawks to
win the nfc west
two to one that line's already come down
sorry if you're late to the party there
i also do agree with master this team
has a shot to make it deep into the
playoffs at 20-1
they win one playoff game we can now
find hedge opportunities
depending on if they're a favorite or
underdog in that second round
i think that there is a good shot here
at twenty to one really
they don't stop it kelly we don't even
have the 12th
what's going to man right now with the
home field advantage we're talking one
point
one and a half weeks particularly in the
nfl without fans these fans
don't matter they don't matter
defense of the seattle seahawks kelly
just
said fans don't matter when all they do
is hoist up a flag with the number 12 on
it
and wilson is able to ride the cheers to
a championship let me tell you guys
something
last year the seahawks in one score game
were nine and two
it's the most regressing stat in the nfl
if they finish five and five now all of
a sudden they're a nine and seven team
i love russell wilson i love dk and loch
and all the guys you said i do not like
their pass rush
i do not like their d line and other
than their left tackle
i don't think anybody here can name an
offensive lineman for the seattle
seahawks
yeah that both of them
are not people you want on your
offensive line i love the seahawks
i think they're a great team i think
they're in the toughest division in
football the nfc west all four of them
are serious
and i i would have rather gone with
masters cowboys i'm i'm surprised he
didn't get the homer pick
he just he loves russell wilson three
ryan
i would have gone with the cowboys but
jerry jones doesn't care about black
lives matter so
hey that is true that is true it's true
well big fat that's true he hasn't said
anything i hope it's not true but
yeah my thing about your pick master my
thing about the pick
hold on kevin let me just jump in here a
lot of the times last year
a lot of the time last year the seahawks
struggled in the first half i don't know
if it was a play calling i don't know if
it was russell and his jitters but
usually in the second half they let russ
slap his wings and go so uh they're
gonna have to fix that for me
this year for them to go and win the
super bowl
but they're also in a division with them
bad boys of san francisco so uh
i don't i don't i don't know about them
winning no super cabbie
where are we at with uh niners counts
for for greg is this the first one right
here the first ten minutes that we're in
now we finally got a niner first
[Laughter]
how did the audience take in masters
pitch okay we got some good ones mullah
mack says boom boom boom and sierra's
goodies we trust
now figure out if clowney will play uh
we have another one up here
uh which said uh
sig money is crowd noise going to be
equivalent across the league or based
off normal decibel levels i don't
understand what that means
the sports feared seahawks are 20-1 for
hawks to make the playoffs that sounds
like stealing money
and this is one brown luke says seahawks
make the playoffs but super bowl is a
pie with peanut butter chocolate banana
and no soggy bottom it ain't happening
wow brown luke with the fuego
i love the specificity of that last
combo i want dessert
that's funny okay so
we might get your dessert here uh you
went with drew brees at plus
2200 on draftkings we just heard from
master taking the seattle seahawks to
win the super bowl at plus 2 000
on draftkings we have the gayuria
represented by a die-hard niners fan who
can
a person who can catch one-handed
footballs with ease
perhaps as a ghost rider for g-eazy
g-money
greg ivory the microphone is yours my
friend
i gotta tap in with my guy g-eazy i do
gotta tap in but i wanna take you guys
to a little city in the bay
by the name of santa clara and there's a
team that plays there yes it is the san
francisco 49ers
and they have a quarterback by the name
of
jimmy g now i've been hearing a lot
about jimmy this offseason
jimmy can't throw jimmy's a game manager
jimmy's a system quarterback
i want you guys to take a look at his
yard total over under for this year
let's get out of our feelings let's look
at this man's progression
over the years he's battled injuries
he's battled back onto the field and in
his first full season
let me repeat that kelly vince master
adam cabbie in his first full season
led the niners to a super bowl and was a
throw away
from being super bowl mvp now you guys
master
adam you guys can take your plus 3 000
plus 5 000
long shots that's not gonna hit give me
my
minus 110 minus 118 whatever it is
guarantee that's gonna hit because jimmy
will be better than he was this season
than last season
let's go take it to the bank i lost
track of how many niners counts we have
here
yeah yeah i see you vy
kelly how do you feel about greg's 49er
niner fandom
so i understand greg's a 49ers fan i'm
gonna put that to the side because greg
did his research he knows that jimmy
threw four more yards on that last year
this one looks a little trappy to me
we know that jimmy is lacking some
weapons outside of george kittle
he's gonna have a lot of dink and dunk
passes they have a super bowl hangover
we've seen this year in a year out what
happened to
vince young's rams last year what
happened to the falcons what happened to
the seahawks what happened to the
patriots
they are the only team that can beat the
super bowl hangover this is just
the bottom line we see what happens and
jimmy
is very good at his job
but he is greg a game manager and i know
you don't want to hear that
he is not any one of the other
quarterbacks we spoke about earlier i
listen you get a great defensive
coordinator
and they are going to figure out jimmy
is a run right
past left kind of guy they're going to
dump the ball off to the back
all day long there's a reason why you
guys have seven or eight running backs
on your roster
because that is gonna be the game plan
talk that troops kelly i don't know
nah she ain't talking no chill you're
gonna run the ball to throw she's not
talking no truth
she ain't talking no truth she ain't
talking no truth on v1 that's a good bet
i'll take it
that's a good bet right though i think
he definitely will be over that for sure
because yes sir because yes sir
kyle shanahan know exactly what he's
doing so he definitely will be over that
for sure
how you doing how are you doing what are
you doing vy you sound like you know you
guys are playing
he didn't look like in the second half
of the super bowl because i played with
him
make sure you know i'm a boy go over
seven thousand
three thousand yards yeah yeah
you throw it for seven thousand oh baby
just for you kelly i'm gonna call them
just for you kelly wait
wait what's your name greg we gotta get
ourselves a side bag here
oh hold on kelly kelly we can talk side
but hold on i hear master asking me
questions like who is he going to be
throwing to like he don't have
george kittle like he doesn't have
jordan reed oh like he doesn't have
jordan
samuels like he doesn't have trent
taylor like he doesn't have
dante pettis is going to have a good
year this year i'm hearing reports out
of santa clara
i'm hearing reports out of santa clara
you got sauces now
dante pettis will have a good one i'm
gonna get dante petty on you
he's got no receivers look i i i think
that the niners can be great master did
you want to jump in here real quick
i just wanted to straight up point out
that i mean divo samuel you coming off
of a uh
injured foot that is not something that
you'll be able to come back from
a hundred percent throughout the course
of the year that on top stop it master
hey i got my asu skirt on okay so you
know i'm a big brand now you
fan i love iuf more than a lot of other
people and i saw his progressions how he
went
but he's already dealing with the
injured hamstring man and on top of that
he's
you can give me george kiddo i'll give
you that okay i covered jordan reed
he has had a history of concussions and
injuries that is going to make him a
liability in terms of my thing
all these other thing about that master
i think about
my thing about that jordan reid's not
even going to see the snap counts that
you were covering him
when you i mean that he saw when you
were covering him he's not going to see
no type of snap
like he was back in the day i mean he's
sitting behind george kittle he's going
to be a
key asset for us um like i said
and debo will be back week one i'm
hearing the report okay mcgregor i need
to know back
who's gonna throw 35-yard 40-yard passes
to
there is no deep man that's how you hit
those type of yardage
numbers for the entire season you gotta
have patrick mahomes ask plays and
jimmy's not that dude
if i would if i was going to say one
last thing before i get to the
conference here that's fine
because they sleeping on him that's why
you're going to do good because they're
sleeping
and greg greg knows this greg knows us
greg knows that the niners run through
that defense
and that they went out and not only gave
mostar more money this year
they went out there and they made sure
jerick mckinnon could come back they got
four running backs and a fullback on
this roster with kittle on the field
they're going heavy formation the entire
time
and they want to win 16 to 10. i love
the niners i think they can be great
but i also don't think they're passing
let me get you some coffee i'm looking
at those in 49
brazil 201 says super bowl loser
hangover is real i wouldn't trust the
niners no matter how good the team is on
paper
jackie boy37 says sorry greg jimmy g
isn't going to pull it out this year
i'm expecting regression let me get to
some positivity i don't want to bash
greg here because he also had some good
stuff well ceelo 0323 says who's
catching the ball outside a kettle
uh that's interesting and then uh nina
tavasky
says greg's optimism is something i wish
i had though
low-key i wish i had great
in the chat too that says cabbie's the
best host ever no
sleep appreciate you appreciate you
all right so the pitches are in uh he
wrote that i didn't say it right then
kelly and vince you guys have heard the
three pitches the audience has heard the
pitches
uh vince who had the best pitch
best pitch with my man g money
money i got to do with the g-money baby
all right going over that and dumping
the yards he's definitely doing that for
sure
he money ain't even making no money
minus one t he ain't making no money
you can't call him jesus bro those other
picks
drew brees is not going to win the mvp
and then seattle like i said they got to
go through the rams so
all those older bets i'm sorry but g has
the best one for show you have the best
one g
yes sir yes sir my god b y know what's
up let's go to our other judge our
betting expert kelly stewart do you
agree with vince young
did greg have the best pitch uh
no i got the worst pitch and i love greg
we work together on a regular basis and
greg and i agree a lot
but greg went with his heart there
we all know my allegiances all fall in
line with dollar bills
adam put up a really good argument and i
i agree with adam
but i really agree with master as i
mentioned that
i had that seahawks team winning the nfc
west i have that seahawks team going
into the playoffs
and we don't need them to win the super
bowl super bowl bets don't make
you money you guys go on the internet
and you see these flashy tickets and you
think oh wow
this is great someone was so smart they
got 20 of those and they just want to be
able to hold up one at the end of the
season
the end of the goal of the end of the
year is to make money at 20 to 1
we can then go into the playoffs we can
start hedging we can guarantee
ourselves money bet on or against the
seahawks in the right spots
master no you talk to them kelly go
hulks
no sir listen like uh like coach mike
singletary once said
i want winners so that's what we're
trying to get so um
you guys have all the information you
need the audience you've heard the
pitches
and it's time to decide on our squad
ride bet of the year
adam lefko rocket withdrawal freeze for
nfl and vp plus 2200.
oh i need more time i got to get they
got to get these votes in here right
okay okay so oh yeah we we
you know what people should do
oh [ __ ] yes we have money to give away i
forgot about the 500 in my pocket
yeah so let's let's do that again
well it's it's the show money uh and
then uh we heard
craig ivory's pitch that jimmy garoppolo
will throw over 3700.5 yards this season
um so while we tally the squad ride let
me get to the 500 bucks
so earlier we asked if on this nfl
football
there are over or under 10 000 dimples
one of you guessed correctly gonna take
over the 500. so we picked two of you
guys from the comments
one of you gets the over one of you
guessed the under
adam lefko tell us who they are okay so
the over is represented by
mulamac and the under is represented by
hudson underscore alas so it's between
them if it's over mulamat gets it if
it's under hudson alas gets it
okay
which one muller mackerel come on max
muller mack
that's a name
all right so let us let us find out who
is going to be 500
richer
oh he really counted him oh damn this
is yeah bro this is like a research that
we do on i hope
you got more than that t-shirt and
canister
gabby how long does it take working i
think this took
six hours oh over city
oh that's a that's a that's a lot of
counting
it's a lot of counting sixteen thousand
sixteen thousand oh no
mack with a w
what was our other competitor's name at
hudson is it hudson hawk
hudson underscore alas
hudson underscore alas don't be too sad
we're going to send you an exclusive br
betting hoodie
um and you can rob and have one of those
[Music]
we'll send one to you too someone to vy
as well
and also congrats to [ __ ] can i get one
and
at two belts that's closest to the
correct answer on our social contest
we're sending both of you some hoodies
so check your dms thank you very much
for playing
uh kelly how much would someone have to
pay you to spend an
afternoon counting all of the dimples on
an nfl football
that looked absolutely miserable and my
problem is i'd probably get bored and
like
re count wrong and then i'd have to
start i don't know we're talking
a couple thousand bucks and then i'd
probably still just find somebody to do
it for half the price put some money in
my pocket and just not even worry about
that
outside kelly's a small business woman
right there she know what you're doing
he is vince that's the check vince you
took the under earlier
are you surprised that those 16 752
dimples on a football
and you've thrown you've thrown those
footballs thousands of times
yeah i was definitely surprised i was
definitely gonna think it was under ten
thousand for a show i was thinking like
nine thousand
but sixteen i'm way off
well audience it's it's now the moment
you've all been waiting for
the squad ride votes are in they've been
tallied yes sir
will you please reveal yeah the winning
bet yes sir
uh so i'm gonna tell you that it really
and i'm i'm not
making this up i'm really gonna give you
the honesty i'm seeing a lot early on
it was between the drew brees bet and
the seattle bet i have seen one person
say g-money and it was his co-worker
mikey locks
uh and i thought it was bad for him
but i myself said which bet should we go
with
and all four people said master
they said let's go good idea but we're
going with master so it appears we are
riding with master of seahawks cabbie
congratulations to master
i'm upset congratulations master test
you know we're gonna give you 15 seconds
to take a bow my friend yeah do it
uh i only have uh two words to really
say everyone is this mike on
go hawks
you're spoken like a true cowboys fan
sure
hey hey listen hey like kelly's saying
we don't we don't bet with our emotions
we we bet with our brains all right
that's what we are
at some point you don't realize that
because the nine is about to have a let
down for you it's all good though
easy money taken you remember when the
seahawks played
the patriots in the super bowl and what
happened of course
yeah that was just the worst play call
in history you can't you got to look at
the entire game down you know
i don't even know
do you know they got to play tom brady
to go to the super bowl
if it's bucks seahawks in the super bowl
i will better rack on the seahawks right
i'm gonna go ahead and say this just for
everybody at home the bucks are gonna be
the most
overvalued team for the first half of
the season bet there's nothing total
under five
tom brady has all these weapons they are
last year's browns team the only upside
is their head coaches the name freddie
kitchens gonna call terrible place
okay i'm riding with kelly
so many gems have been dropped on squad
ride it's been amazing so thank you guys
for rocking with us
before we get out of here we have to
award somebody a playstation 5 which
comes out in a couple of months
we have access we're giving one to vince
and we're giving one to somebody at home
so and you also get a copy of madden 21
with lamar jackson on the cover
uh can you please reveal who is winning
a playstation 5. i feel as though
because i don't want any hate i am going
to scroll up
and i'm going to put my finger down and
wherever it lands that's who gets it
okay
so don't be in my mentions okay
[Laughter]
wow deke geek d
geek and what's incredible is it's
literally on the one that says
can i get a hoodie with crying emojis
emojis
now you get to cry for joy deep geek
let's ride
a ps5 wow damn
[Laughter]
congratulations to all our winners
tremendous response love that you guys
are firing off hot takes in the comments
you decided we are hammering the seattle
seahawks
that is our squad ride we are betting as
a family plus 2 000 on draftkings
well done master test with a winning
pitch um
send us your screenshots of your bets
like single terry says we want winners
and
kelly chad and some of you guys will
only show your winners that's okay
because we like them and we're gonna
repost them if our squad ride hits you
guys get br hoodies
thank you to vince young thank you to
master test thank you to lefko for
joining the vr betting squad
shout out to kelly stewart and greg
ivory for being a part of the family
thank you guys all for commenting we'll
be back in week one and
you know we're gonna need your help to
pick a week one squad ride
so rock with us then appreciate you guys
for joining us
we will see you guys soon peace
so
[Music]
you